Je pense que c'est un chemin qui
n'importe qui aurait trouvé cela impossible
faire le tour de la fille de barranquilla
Colombie qui commence dans un marché où
qui n'existait pas vraiment a soutenu le
talent national comme aujourd'hui, par exemple,
talent local et talent colombien
les portes ont été ouvertes comme c'est fait
Aujourd'hui à ce moment j'ai dû me battre
pour être une fille pour être une femme pour être
artiste pop dans un monde où
la salsa tropicale prédominait
le merengue les rythmes
local autochtone alors oui c'était
une bataille difficile à mener mais quand même
c'est pourquoi je pense que moi aussi
remplit d'une grande satisfaction tout ce
chemin parcouru
Eh bien, s'ils me disaient que ça ressemblait à une chèvre
mes amies
depuis je pense que c'était une façon
intimidation passive mais j'ai réussi
surtout que nous continuons notre
amitié avec qui je suis toujours resté ami
mes amis et moi avons compris que je n'avais pas à
changer quoi que ce soit en moi pour leur plaire
Mon père et ma mère m'ont beaucoup aidé là-dessus.
aussi qu'ils m'ont appris à valoriser mon
voix pour valoriser mon talent à la fin
je garde le vibrato et c'est devenu
une nouvelle façon de me signer en tant que fille
à l'adolescence j'étais plein de
insécurités et mes parents étaient les
personnes qui ont réaffirmé ma validation
et grâce à eux j'ai pu avancer
et retourné aux tests de costumes
Je déteste si ça ne tenait qu'à moi, je ferais tout mon
activités artistiques en uniforme oui
c'était pour moi le truc avec les vêtements c'est mal
nécessaire
d'habitude c'est moi qui monte mes
propres chorégraphies mais pas parce que
personne ne peut le surmonter évidemment il y a
beaucoup de danseurs
de bien meilleurs paladins et chorégraphes
que j'aime juste ça
Je les crée parce que je me sens bien je me sens
la musique est plus dans mon corps plus
intégré dans les mouvements du jet lorsque
ils sont les leurs parce qu'ils sont beaucoup plus faciles
pour moi aussi
l'apprentissage est difficile pour moi d'apprendre
les chorégraphies des autres aussi mais oui
je l'ai fait
à de nombreuses reprises lorsque j'ai
travaillé avec des chorégraphes mais pour la plupart
En général, on finit toujours par collaborer
tu finis toujours par faire un
collaboration et j'ai toujours fini là
impliqué dans tous les détails
mensonges et j'aime la nourriture
cuisine colombienne pour moi
C'est mon préféré parce qu'il s'agit bien sûr de
tout si si je ne suis pas si longtemps dans mon
pays quand je sors et que quelqu'un me dit
offre un plat colombien est un morceau
du ciel, c'est comme manger un morceau de
chéri
bien parce que ce n'est pas exactement un remix
est une version tout est né de celle dans le
quand nous étions sur le plateau de
mauvais chantage un an on a commencé à danser
la salsa et là l'idée d'être un
version sauce chantage
Je ne considérerais pas cela comme un échec non plus
parce que c'était mon premier album m'a permis
commencer une carrière, je pense que c'était parce que
au contraire une réussite
évidemment pas comparable à
albums ultérieurs quand il y avait de la flamme
a duré en tant qu'artiste mais pour faire un
fille que tu devais aggraver avait enregistré ça
album avec des chansons qu'il avait écrites
entre 8 et 13 ans imaginez et
ont eu l'occasion de sortir avec
un label en tant qu'artiste
professionnel à un si jeune âge je pense
ce serait plutôt pourrait envisager
un succès
aussi la pluie parce qu'ils ont
C'est super amusant, surtout pour les enfants.
enfants et je vois mes propres enfants qui
quand il pleut comme ça ça dit avec cette pluie
torrentiel ils veulent sortir et se mouiller
et les adultes veulent toujours protéger
aux enfants bien qu'il pleuve mais
Dire que la pluie est amusante
C'est vrai, j'ai appris à écrire pour lire
très très tôt ma mère s'est occupée de
que j'ai appris à lire et à écrire mon
Plus tôt j'ai fait la même chose avec mon milan
fils aîné la seconde je l'ai déjà un peu quitté
plus en paix
et la rose doit être là était le premier poème
Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait à ma mère? Je le lui ai donné le jour de
les mères et là à partir de là je me suis donné
dit que j'aimais écrire et que
c'était un moyen d'expression qui allait être
vital pour moi
pas avant l'été n'a pas réussi à obtenir
mais si je dois sortir beaucoup de musique, ça va
tirant des chansons d'ici à la fin de
année et j'ai déjà l'arminia
terminé et je veux vraiment
commencer à leur montrer la musique
Chansons